let me set this up for you so
for those of you who don't know and i
hate that it sounds egotistical for me
to bring up my previous work but i've
done some videos on islam
uh up on youtube or you can go to
louderwithcrowder.com and see these
where really i just take quotes from the
actual quran or the hadith
from muhammad's life or i guess
historical accounts the canonized texts
and and used them and said listen what
do you folks think about this
issue the koran challenge where i
challenge people to read
five pages in any direction anywhere in
the quran
and tell me if their opinion has changed
listen my
assertion is that it is a book of power
of violence and of hatred
as compared to the new testament where
it was kind of about loving and and
being good to your neighbor with the
exception of jesus kind of going you
know going a little bit crazy in the
temple but that was well worn that was
well warranted it was merited
uh so there's this islamic nonprofit
called talk
islam by the way very effective with
online mujahideen i guess jihadi tactics
where they flood any page that's
negative about islam you need to know
this online if ever you say anything
that's remotely critical about islam
you will be flooded by armies of online
islamists down voting your videos trying
to get it removed from
as hate speech i've had to go to youtube
several times and say listen this video
is not hay speech it's directly quoting
the quran
so there's a video up now from talk
islam.org with a character who is trying
to rebut
all of my arguments arguments i made
taking quotes directly from the quran
and he really thinks he's gotten the
better
of all i guess people critical of islam
through me so we're going to bring on
actually somebody who helps me source a
lot of these videos a very educated man
a guy who actually teaches these courses
at churches
as it relates to christian apologetics
and muslim apologetics across the
country
gerald morgan gerald thanks for coming
back absolutely man thanks for having me
on again i appreciate it
yes we are grateful to have last time
you were in studio so now we're doing
this via phone
which uh hopefully doesn't make it uh
too much harder i know you're on
you're on central time so you're
probably pretty groggy yeah you know
woke up about six seven minutes ago but
i'm good well
hopefully you have some caffeine in you
because we need you to help us with this
so
uh fun dip we're gonna roll some clips
here we're gonna roll some clips from
this video and we're going to dissect it
for you the listener so listen
you don't have to watch the whole video
yourself we're going to rebut the common
islamic arguments defending the faith
fundip run clip 1 please
jesus verse muhammad peace be upon them
both because both of them are prophets
of islam and for that reason i will
respect both because they were the best
of men
to walk this earth so that's the first
quote we have from this gentleman by the
way who was very offended at me
uh for being pro-jesus and not
necessarily pro-muhammad
that's that's the setup that's the
premise both men
the best men to walk the face of this
earth gerald do you agree with that
no no and i have respect for people of
every faith um
except for for this one specifically
because we have we found a guy here
in uh in muhammad who's really going out
and lying to people
and he's one of the most nefarious
characters in history
and i'm not trying to dog him because i
disagree with the ideology there's a lot
of things that i disagree with in life
but i'm really going after him because
you cannot compare
the sinless life of jesus christ to
somebody who
told his followers to kill jews to
somebody who told his followers
to go out and commit these atrocities if
people don't convert there's just
absolutely no way that you can make that
comparison not with a straight face
he's kind of like a walking um a walking
cess or baron cohen character i'm not
quite sure how to handle them
but uh no that's great to set up the
premise here again secular argument this
isn't even an argument from a christian
perspective if you don't believe jesus
is who he said he is
nor muhammad uh let's just compare their
lives historically but we're going to go
on to the next point we've got to roll
through this
uh fun dip roll clip two please in
regards to your first
allegation of prophet muhammad peace be
upon him marrying a minor
all i can say is that islam is the only
religion to actually prohibit
the marriage of minors who have not
reached the age of puberty
the truth is in different times in
different places in different contexts
the age for marriage varies let's leave
it at that with a question now of course
this was in response to me
talking about the fact that muhammad for
those of you who don't know
married a six-year-old chick named aisha
to be fair he may be consummated when
she was nine
also hit her we'll get to that later
here's the thing gerald
he doesn't really rebut anything he just
tries to blur
historical contexts no actually he goes
one step further than that and he admits
that even in the quran it says not to
marry a minor
i i don't know if maybe muhammad wasn't
you know paying attention when he wrote
that
but he turned around and did just that
and married a six-year-old
i mean there's a word and maybe i
shouldn't use it on the air but there's
a word that we have for people
using our age group that you i mean and
we would call somebody who marries a
six-year-old today
a pedophile that's exactly what that
person would be called
well hold on hold on gerald hold on
gerald they would have been called a
pedophile back then
it's not yet it's not one of those
things it's like listen people go i get
it people got married at 13 14 which is
why it was also easier for people to
wait
uh to have sex until marriage now people
are going through their second
adolescence getting married at 35
but even back then six years old
even nine if that's when he consummated
that's before girls even get their
monthly cycle
that's before girls become women that
that would have been a pedophile
back then so again we're gonna go to the
next clip here real quick but he doesn't
even rebut that just tries to blur those
lines now let's go on to his next
argument
fun dip clip three please since this is
jesus versus muhammad let's compare it
to the context of jesus
with none other than the best of women
to have walked this earth
mary the mother of jesus she got married
to joseph
who was 90 years old when she was only
12 years old
okay um i've i've searched for this high
and low gerald
and i can only find very small fringe
websites usually pro-islamic websites
that use that argument is there any kind
of
historical backing that joseph was 90
years old
no there's no legitimate backing in fact
there's a lot of things that really make
this
impossible right when's the he's he's
kind of termed as the carpenter's son
and that's how he was making his living
how many 90-year-old carpenters do you
know that are out there running around
and making a living or how about making
a trek down to egypt
right you know when jesus was born they
had to get out of that they had to get
out of the land for a little while
okay but maybe when jesus was 12 and he
was 102 years old
running around the temple trying to find
jesus i mean they must have had a great
health care system back then because we
can't even do that today
yeah well they did they had the thing is
they had a better roll out to their
health care back
yeah it was better websites i think yeah
exactly they had a better website really
it was just a sundial where they
sacrificed a few goats
but it's funny that this guy sets us 90
years old and like you said i guess if
you're you know clint eastwood gran
torino maybe at 90 you can get a few
kids off of
off of your lawn you just never age i
guess maybe that's what happened right
now
i guess he's sort of extrapolating from
the fact and you've talked about this
before that joseph is portrayed
in in some christian works of art um it
didn't really take place until after the
fourth century he was maybe portrayed a
little older
yeah yeah and it was in kind of a
misguided attempt they didn't want
people to associate joseph as being the
biological father
of jesus not because he he was and they
were trying to cover it up it was just
because they were trying to
kind of put a point on the divinity of
christ right so they started to kind of
portray him as this older man so it
wouldn't look like
he was legitimately the father of jesus
so it was a misguided attempt and again
there's been plenty of those in the
church
even so i mean it's not like mary was a
perpetual virgin her whole life
right no no she had more children which
again and i you know i mean
goodness you know kudos to joseph if he
was 90 some odd years old popping out
six more kids or five more kids
um that's that's pretty impressive in my
book yeah that was before cialis i guess
but uh he must have had going on
all right we're going to go on here to
the next clip we'll roll uh through
these so the next clip if you can run it
fun dip please another thing you
mentioned
jihad and as much as you say that the
bible doesn't have verses on jihad
after church today pull out your bible
and look up psalm 137
and you'll see that our own text has
passages
that can make us uncomfortable and islam
teaches you how to and we don't shy away
from it
okay so jihad is a word that gets people
pretty uncomfortable
right gerald and again he doesn't seem
to deny anything that's been said in any
of my videos or anything that that i
guess critics would say
he just tries to blur historical context
that's what you're seeing here saying
well it's kind of like liberals with
barack obama george bush did it worse
it's the same thing muslims go well
christians did it too
um tell us about jihad and is there
anywhere that
christians could could interpret
something like that from their texts
no and and that's i guess the big point
for me is that yes there are accounts of
historical violence
in the bible and in the quran right
that's not what we're talking about here
and let me just really quick
psalm 137 is absolutely 100
not talking about jihad it's talking
about a people who have been taken
captive by the babylonians saying god
when are you going to judge
these people for all the atrocities
they've done for us okay so first of all
that's fine
the second is jihad is a struggle right
right i don't know why
but for some reason by the way reading
the quran is a struggle have you ever
slogged through that fiction
oh my gosh it makes twilight look
brilliant gerald we're going to bring
you on after the break
it's so thorough we appreciate it so
folks stick around
we're going to finish dissecting the
islamic apologist
arguments louder with crowder don't
change the dial
[Music]
so gerald morgan thank you so much for
staying with us
yeah absolutely man thanks okay so we
were talking about before you left uh
the jihad
quote which we did we'll run this on the
ladder with credit.com where this
gentleman says that uh you know
jihad can be found in in christian in
in you know the old testament texts that
it can be really interpreted that way in
any religion
you say no why i say no because the
entire bible
the message is a god who lovingly
pursues you
right and then basically at the very end
says look one day you're going to be
accountable for the decision that you
make but until that day i'm going to do
everything that i can to show you who i
am and to show you that i love you
right message is not in islam the
religion of peace quote unquote right
it's definitely not there basically it
says either you convert
right here right now by some verbal
thing which has nothing to do with your
heart if you've got a sword
on the back of your neck and you've got
to convert or die right
that's that's the message of jihad or
convert
exactly and that's where you go into if
you don't convert you know or die you
know there's the dimitude there's sharia
law where i mean you want to talk about
people feeling like second-class
citizens here in the united states
because maybe they're in some kind of a
minority group
try being non-muslim in any muslim
country if you're still alive by the way
it usually doesn't make it to
to dimitude and putting you in a role
that is submissive to muslims and
society usually you're just
you know you're just decapitated but
that's a great point really it's the
overarching message of
of whether again whether you're a
christian or not even if you're an
atheist
you have to appreciate the concept of a
god that's about love the consequence of
god about forgiveness
or at least it's part of the concept and
a god that's about power
and killing absolutely big differences
just it freaks me out that's a huge
difference well we're going to run the
last clip here
and then we can kind of just sort of
wrap it all up a fun dip
dan if you could run the last clip from
talk islam please
and islam even made responsibility on
everyone participating in war
you do not hurt the trees you do not
hurt the elderly the children the women
where are your ethics of war like we
have ethics of war i have two words for
you
predator drones i don't know what the
obama thing came in there at the end of
that that was a
that was a weird trend everybody kind of
giggled i
i have to say though i love that he
started out with not hurting the trees
right that's fantastic who is he james
cameron tree's in good shape
yeah he's gonna he's gonna be an avatar
too but i find some
ethics of war so obviously trees we're
talking about animals we're talking
about
i guess not reporters are they are
are they no no no apparently not and and
here's the thing uh
all of those things that he listed would
be great if
anyone actually adhered to them in war
right
so this is a great list to throw out
there but unfortunately if it's just
it doesn't do anybody any good because
you know there's tons of human shields
that have been used
i mean recently with gaza that's been
one of the claims uh that we've had to
deal with
and you know their treatment of women as
human shield as well right i don't
understand where and this one if it
wasn't so sad almost made me laugh
that he said that islam has ethics of
war with everything that we see going on
right now in islam and all the wars that
have been going on in the middle east
forever
yeah where are the ethics i have no idea
what he's caught no it is
it's laughable almost as laughable as by
the way as this gentleman's beard
i feel bad because i know it's big in
those cultures and the guy just can't
grow one it's
it's got to be a tough gig for a guy
like that to not be able to grow a beard
and work for talk islam i mean here's
the thing
if we're talking about if it's actually
really in you know practiced
um i mean long before any americans got
involved or even if you want to talk
about israel hamas there are far
more you know islamic groups i mean you
look at syria killing other
other muslims that happens all over the
world and really if it was we don't want
to hurt the trees we don't want to hurt
any person those are the ethics of war
if i'm a muslim or even a christian in
syria
i say hey i just go sit next to a tree
that's what i do
you know which are hard to find in very
arid places it is maybe that's why
that's probably why jesus got so mad at
the fig tree when he was over there in
that area of the world because there
were warnings
one fig tree i've gotten it doesn't do
anything right i always that's the one
thing
that's the one thing jesus seemed like
he got a little bit too mad oh man you
never bear fruit again you know the
apostles are sitting there going hey
jesus we can
calm down there's just some figs we can
go down to the temple and buy you some
figs they're selling things at the
temple
and then you know everybody's running
doves are flying
lambs are ewing right exactly this is
one of those things so so here's again
again gerald the most
important thing i think to take away
here is this is a guy who
i guess by all measurable barometers or
at least he claims to or at least talk
islam thinks this guy is qualified
enough to do so
has the credentials to defend islam this
is the guy who's come out a video that's
been watched i think almost a million
times
and yet i've never really seen any kind
of counter arguments to the arguments
that i put forth in the video and by the
way my arguments aren't unique it's the
same arguments that people have put
forward against the quran
and muhammad and islam for years and the
best it seems as though he has correct
me if i'm wrong is
well christians do it too and here's a
verse sort of blurring the historical
context
absolutely no that's he doesn't address
any of the issues i mean really this guy
it should be a you know left-leaning
democrat he's perfect for the role
he just says no wait a minute look over
here don't don't look at the fact that
it's in our book
not to do this and muhammad did this
don't worry about that but look over
here and look at this where maybe you
guys have done something bad in the past
right exactly this doesn't make any
sense good call with a left-wing
democrat way to tie it back into
politics i could see funding
back my friend fun dip is giving you a
slow clap right now
he's standing up like standing
[Music]